this is democracy now
democracynow.org the war and peace
report i'm amy goodman in new york
joined by democracy now co-host juan
gonzalez in new brunswick new jersey
hi amy welcome to all of our listeners
and viewers across the country and
around the world
well the ransom that's the name of a
major series of articles published by
the new york times detailing how haiti
became one of the poorest countries in
the world while bankers in france and
the united states made a fortune the
story dates back to the early 19th
century in 1804 the enslaved people of
haiti
rose up leading a rebellion against
french colonial rule founding the
world's first black republic
under military threat from france in
haiti agreed to pay reparations to
france for lost so-called property
including enslaved people that french
owners lost in the rebellion
france threatened to invade haiti and
reimpose slavery if haiti did not agree
to a staggering amount
in reparations 150
million francs 30 times haiti's annual
revenue haiti began taking out loans
from french banks leading to an economic
crisis that continues through to this
day
the new york times estimates haiti paid
the equivalent of what's now 560 million
dollars to france over the next seven
decades
the true economic cost to haiti is
estimated to be an astounding
115 billion dollars and that only tells
a part of the story
in 1880 a french bank established
haiti's first national bank essentially
putting france in control of haiti's
treasury
that bank
credit industrial ecomarcial used some
of its massive profits to help finance
the eiffel tower
the bank's current
owner has just launched an investigation
into its dealings with haiti and its
role in what's called the ecosystem of
colonialism that bank cic
the time series also looks at the u.s
military occupation of haiti that lasted
from 1915 to 1934.
a key backer of the u.s occupation was
the national citibank of new york the
predecessor of citibank
former u.s diplomat patrick aspar who
knew heads who now heads the center for
american progress has called on
citigroup to pay reparations to haiti
gaspard wrote on twitter
a silent scream has been in throats for
decades about the role u.s played in
depleting haiti
no one would listen finally some truths
he said
over the years haitian demands for
reparations have been repeatedly shut
down
sometimes with force
france's former ambassador to haiti
terry bukar admitted to the new york
times that france and the united states
effectively orchestrated the 2004 coup
that ousted haiti's first democratically
elected president jean-bertrand arrested
berkard said one benefit of the coup was
that it ended aristide's campaign
demanding france pay financial
reparations to haiti
to talk more about haiti and the
devastating impact of colonialism in
this massive series in the new york
times we're joined by two guests
westonly also not is a haitian-american
professor at fordham university where he
teaches courses on the atlantic slave
trade the american abolition movement
and afro-caribbean history gerald horn
also joins us he's professor of history
and african-american studies at the
university of houston author of many
books including confronting black
jacobins the u.s the haitian revolution
and the origins of the dominican
republic
we welcome you both to democracy now
professor assanad let's begin with you
so this series has come out in the new
york times to both criticism and praise
it's come out in both creole and in
english that's a first for the new york
times can you explain the significance
of what many are calling revelations at
least to the general public but
certainly people in haiti have been
alleging for centuries not only alleging
but of course having proof of this
yes um
thank you amy thank you for um having me
today i'm glad to be here in
conversation with you so first let me
start by saying that um a great uh
acknowledgement to the many reporters
and producers who put this uh very
special issue together and um to have
given it a front-time exposure um it
will mean a lot um not really for
haitians per se because this the the
facts that are being revealed throughout
the report are very well known even to
the most um illiterate haitian um and
even to the youngest haitian grown up in
fact given the
level of underdevelopment that is
prevalent in haiti today
one knows at least the haitian people
knows that this could have only been the
legacy of an external force rather of
their own making so i think the
significance of the piece will be that
it exposes the rest of the world to a
knowledge that actually has existed for
over a hundred years and shares multiple
partners both in the private sector with
regards to the financial industry as
well as the united states government um
germany great britain and
most certainly and and most influential
friends
having played a role in imposing the
debt that in many ways will explain
haiti's uh poverty today so i welcome
the piece i think it's great uh in terms
of the many research that it it brought
together both from academic literature
that had already existed as well as new
revelations that are coming up but in
terms of calling it revelations
that would be a misnomer i myself have
written it very extensively on the
subject
many other fellow academic historians
i've written about it there have been
movements over the decades to get the
united states france and the other
parties
responsible for this
to get them to some accountability and
um
and i believe
a large reason why this never got the
fair sort of ear of of listening that it
should have gotten is because it's
coming from um haitians who many people
um view as sort of the africans of the
western hemisphere but which is an
identity that haitians proudly wear um
where proudly for for reasons that
reasonably make sense for it in terms of
the freedom that they fought and
established for all black people
yeah i'd like to bring in uh professor
gerald horne to the conversation another
historian who has covered the issue of
of colonialism imperialism and slavery
throughout the americas for decades uh i
too was uh had the same feeling that a
lot of this
is only new to people who haven't paid
attention to the history of the western
hemisphere
over the last several hundred years i'm
wondering your reaction to uh to the uh
the piece because the times really is
delving into history uh much more than
news i think the the most interesting
aspect of it was the particular
uh individuals in france and and the
institutions that directly benefited uh
from uh the ransom that haiti was caused
was forced to pay but largely this is
this is a history that is known by
people who know any part of the history
of of latin america and of the western
hemisphere so imagine your reaction to
the piece as a historian who studied
this carefully
well first of all i would urge and
encourage the new york times to follow
through with their point that they have
uncovered new documents
by putting these documents online so
that other historians can take advantage
of their excavations
and or secondly placing them at the new
york times archive which i believe has
been cited at the new york public
library
but i think that the story also is of
significance and of moment for us in the
united states for we in the united
states because
there has been this myth that has been
created that the united states and the
haitian revolution
were
twins even though we know
as i begin my book on the haitian
revolution george washington the
founding father of this country was
quite nervous about the eruption in
haiti in august 1791 and this was
understandable because the haitian
revolution culminating in 1804 led to a
general crisis of the entire slave
system in the americas that could only
be resolved with its collapse
therefore the united states was probably
second to friends and being an
antagonist of the haitian people
from their point of view this was a
reaction to the fact
that many of the slave revolts in the
united states had haitian fingerprints
all over them i'm speaking of gabriel's
revolt in virginia in 1800 the revolt in
louisiana circa 1811 denmark vesey about
a decade later in south carolina in fact
destiny had sailed in vessel had sailed
in and out of haiti before that eruption
in charleston south carolina
and then
culminating this hostility to haiti
there is substantial evidence to suggest
that when the island the island that we
refer to as hispaniola was split in 1844
with the secession from haiti of what
became the dominican republic
that this was an early success for u.s
covert operations
so
this story in the new york times is of
significance for we in the united states
hopefully it will cause us to re-examine
the history of this country and move
away from the propaganda point that
somehow the united states was an
abolitionist republic when actually it
was the foremost slaveholders republic
and i'm wondering also if it wouldn't
have been uh uh
worthwhile for the new york times to do
it another piece on its own coverage of
haiti over the past 100 years or so i'm
thinking back for instance during the
first coup uh against president aristide
when there were numerous articles in the
new york times about how aristide was
considered to be mentally unstable and
and uh and uh and erratic in his uh
behavior all of it fed to it by
intelligence uh sources uh and even the
times his coverage perhaps of the the
u.s occupation that long occupation in
the early 20th century
the time seems to be willing to go after
france uh and the us but really doesn't
look at its uh its own role in creating
the narrative of haiti as a
dysfunctional country wondering what you
think about that gerald
well you're absolutely correct obviously
criticism should be accompanied by
self-criticism and there is much work to
be done in that sphere by the new york
times you mentioned the occupation
1915-1934
the united states did not excuse me the
new york times did not necessarily
stress and emphasize in their coverage
the mass opposition to the u.s
occupation particularly by black
americans particularly by a founder of
the naacp speaking of w.e.b du bois who
as you know his ancestral roots
were in fact on the island and he led a
vigorous campaign against this murderous
and bloodthirsty occupation that in some
ways involve the
reassertion of unpaid labor the
so-called corvae as it was called
euphemistically in haiti and the new
york times would do well to re-examine
its own coverage because hopefully that
would improve today's coverage
well i want to go back to 2004
juan just referred to this
france's former ambassador to haiti has
admitted france and the united states
effectively orchestrated the 2004 coup
that overthrew haitian president jean
patron aristide haiti's first
democratically elected president the
former french ambassador terry bukar
told the new york times one benefit of
the coup was that it ended aristide's
campaign demanding france pay
reparations to haiti
i want to turn to an interview we did
with kim ives of haiti liberte this was
right after president aristide was put
on a plane
and sent to the central african republic
this was what kim ives
described
this is a u.s french-led operation in
fact didn't aristide say he holds the
french ambassador to haiti
as well responsible for his kidnapping
and wants to bring charges yes the
french were involved in all this
pressure and in fact uh were in some
ways leading the charge this was a
purely u.s french operation
and of course france probably more than
the united states had more to lose from
irisd
continuing in the presidency since he
was beginning to
lay claim to
to reparations from france for the
period of colonialism and slavery well
this is precisely it you had the
restitution for
2.21.7 billion dollars which was on the
table
and we saw a lot of rivalries were
put aside to get aristide out between
the ruling groups in haiti of the
comprador bourgeoisie and the big land
owners who generally are constantly
squabbling throughout haitian history
for power they put aside their
differences to get together which we see
with andy uphead representing the
bourgeoisie and gee philippe and jodel
champlain more than makut wing and we
saw the france in the us who have also
been sort of vying put aside their
differences so you saw this this
union unity come between uh rivals
against aristide because he represented
uh the people and because he he was a
representative of popular will in haiti
so just to be clear this is mid-march
2004 that kim ives was speaking
right after that democracy now i flew to
the central african republic on a small
plane covering a group of
african-american activists and
politicians including randall robinson
of transafrica
as well as
congressmember maxine waters
to
who went to the central african republic
to retrieve the our steeds and then
brought them back to the western
hemisphere as the u.s government was
saying how dare you bring them to
this hemisphere
to which randall robinson responded
whose hemisphere they eventually brought
them to haiti and the aristides then
went to exile in south africa for years
before they
eventually went back to
haiti where they are today
i'd like to get response starting with
professor
horn and then
professor alcinat about the significance
of these coups whether we're talking
about aristide
in the early 90s or again
in 2004 the coups against them and what
that meant for this country i mean no
president again
would demand reparations
well the reparations questions is
obviously key uh keep in mind that what
makes the united states unique is that
the slave owners were expropriated their
property and the bodies of the slave
africans was taken without compensation
that helped to give rise to the
terrorism of the ku klux klan
in haiti as we've been discussing the
haitians were obligated to pay back
believe it or not the enslavers and
likewise if you look at the british
possession so-called jamaica barbados
etc
you had london
compensate the enslavers and by some
measures
that total was not paid off until just a
few years ago and so this question of
reparations is quite key
and also quite key is the role of haiti
in helping to ignite this entire process
of abolition leading to capital loss not
least in the united states of america
the enslaving class and their
descendants have a very long memory they
have not forgotten haiti's role that's
why they continue to punish haiti
for having the temerity to rise up
against slavery
and even today they continue to punish
havery because haiti because they see
haiti as a haven for low-wage labor
u.s baseballs in the u.s national
pastime are largely manufactured by
cheap labor in haiti so there is still
much to sort out with regard to this
entire controversy and professor alcinat
if you could also respond right through
today to the uh u.s diplomat uh patrick
gaspard who now runs center for american
progress demanding citibank launch an
investigation and the whole issue of
reparations whether you could see it
actually being real given the
devastation of haiti
um okay thank you amy i think i want to
quickly uh go back to
uh what was asked with regards to the
new york times let me remind our
audience that it was in 2010
um not just days after an earthquake had
devastated the country and killed
upwards of 200
and more people
that the new york times provided a
platform
for
one of its columnist david brooks
to say some of the most racist things
that i've ever read
in the new york times about haiti um so
if we are going to also give the new
york times the credit for what is a
phenomenal job about talking
on this issue they should also
start by apologizing for what mr brooks
had said then which let me quote real
quick haiti like most of the world's
poorest nations suffers from a complex
web of progress resistant cultural
influences there is the influence of the
voodoo religion which spreads the
message that life is capricious and
planning futile
there are high levels of social mistrust
responsibility is often not internalized
child rearing practices often involve
neglect in the early years in harsh
retribution when kids hit nine or ten
we're all supposed to politely respect
each other's cultures but some cultures
are more progress resistant than others
and a horrible tragedy was just
exacerbated by one of them so i call on
the new york times
to both acknowledge the statements of
racist um
demography
on its pages from uh mr david brooks as
anyone can judge for themselves they can
go back and look at um the op-ed um and
it's
pseudo intellectual uh
anthropologizing of haitians so that's
one and with regards to mr gaspar i
believe he actually served
in the
uh obama administration
and most people should know that
president obama being himself the first
black african-american president of the
united states actually never made an
official visit to the first black
republic in the world
the very nation
without which mr obama would have not
assumed the role
of leading a society like the united
states as he had so i would like to know
from mr gaspar why is that the
administration never actually took the
very official
position that he is taking right now
with regards to um haitian poverty and
under development and the explicit role
that the united states france
canada and germany have played in all of
that
and then lastly i just want to uh uh
respond to your question with regards to
just the immensity of the debt
and and the destructive legacy it has
had for haiti um the tragedy of all of
this is that even
um what's this debt is paid if it were
to ever be paid um which i like
professor horn i believe uh there are
parties that are invested in never
actually making um realizing that
possibility even if that debt were to be
paid we are already talking about
decades
of gaps in development that were missed
in the process because of where the
money was going something like upwards
to 80 of all haitian expenditures up
until uh the early part
of
the 20th century was going to financing
the debt and the fact that american
firms from wall street
and cahoots with the federal uh
government in terms of
the state department the navy
uh and you have
uh names like general smedley butler who
actually wrote about his role as a
marines and haiti and how he secured
the
interests of the financial
corporate groups as well as
working with the state department to
make sure that haiti
becomes a haven uh for capitalism as as
he said and um and also we can even see
uh fdr president um franklin delano
roosevelt himself had been um secretary
of the navy um upon the uh the time that
haiti was invaded and becoming a
protectorate essentially of the united
states and he too
um had professed to actually
amending the haitian constitution
to take out a very revolutionary
constitutional
uh clause that had banned
white
male
from owning land in haiti among the
first constitutional clauses that the
occupation targeted was that and
therefore opened the country up to
internal uh meddling
by the international powers but lastly i
just want to to also note the fact that
uh with regards to what you had said
about the eiffel tower um
credit indus industrial uh which is now
a part of credit agriculture one of the
largest banks in the world i think among
the 10th largest banks in the world
having funded
the building of the eiffel tower which
is now this massive
monument to french industrial progress
that it was happening at a moment in
which the united states france germany
and parts of western europe were
developing rapidly from the capital that
they were extracting from many of their
former colonies or their current
colonies so imagine
what would the history of development in
haiti
be today
if at the same time that the world is
undergoing industrial transformations
the likes of which
we see today in the form of the eiffel
tower what if that money that was taken
from haiti financing french
infrastructure was financing haitian
infrastructure instead the fact of the
matter is there is no progress resistant
genes that somehow haitians are born
with perhaps someone like david brooks
was born with that with some
uh progress resistant gene as he is
unable to fathom that haitians can take
care of themselves um but the truth uh
goes to show where the receipts are in
terms of uh why we know haiti is in the
position that it is today
i'd like to ask
gerald horn uh the the bank aspect of
this reporting which i to me
uh is i
i think the most newsworthy in that the
times actually was able to get a hold uh
in french archives of
financial arrangements uh that were made
between banking interests in france uh
uh and uh haiti as well as uh
it's uncovering or more deeply
uncovering the role of first national
city bank in the early 20th century uh
in haiti
uh so i think that this is some of the
best uh stuff in this report
but it's almost like um hey new york
times discovers imperialism uh the uh
isn't the role of wall street and
european banks in controlling the
economies not just of haiti but of
honduras of nicaragua of of cuba of many
of these uh
countries in latin america part of the
uh
the operational mode of of american
imperialism
most definitely and i think that the
series laudable as it has been
could also have made a contribution if
it had pointed out the close connections
between
france and the united states that is to
say
in the 20th century they began to talk
about the citibank and citicorp and how
it was involved in the depredations
inflicted upon haiti but i think if you
were to go back to the haitian
revolutionary period you would also find
similar connections after all we know
that what became the united states was
involved in a revolt against london that
would not have succeeded without the
assistance of france
we know that there was substantial
france french migration uh
states and that the french men were
involved in similar depredations in
louisiana and slave owning for example
we know that when texas seceded from
mexico in 1836
that texas major diplomatic ally on the
international front happened to be
france and we also know that when the
united states civil war erupted 1861 to
1865 it was friends that
opportunistically chose that moment to
try to seize and occupy mexico
and then as
the lease on life of slavery in texas
and throughout the south
by welcoming slave owners from texas and
from dixie into french occupied mexico
and it took a mass revolt by the mexican
people to overturn
that particular scheme so there is much
more digging and excavation that needs
to be done and i would like to reiterate
my call
for the new york times to open the
kimono and to disgorge these documents
they say that they have uncovered in
france so that other scholars and other
researchers can examine same we haven't
even talked about the louisiana purchase
but we can't in this show however i want
to end on uh the crisis
that haitians confront today when they
try to come into the united states
i think it was last september the u.s
special envoy to haiti resigned in
protest over the biden administration's
policies in a letter the long-time
diplomat
u.s
envoy to haiti daniel foote wrote i will
not be associated with the united states
inhumane counterproductive decision to
deport thousands of haitian refugees
foot also criticized the by
demonstration for meddling in haiti's
political affairs including its support
for ariel henry as prime minister
following the assassination of haitian
president jovenel malice in july
foote's resignation came just days after
u.s border patrol agents on horseback
were filmed chasing grabbing and
whipping haitian asylum seekers who
gathered in that makeshift camp in del
rio texas we only have a minute
professor also not but the issue of
haitian refugees being deported by the
thousands back to a devastated haiti
oh well real quick i think what uh
you've just demonstrated is that haiti
stands as a singular metaphor for
understanding the racial legacy of
imperial powers like the united states
and france in fact as the war in ukraine
is happening the sheer
magnitude of the difference in the
treatment of certain refugees because of
their european background relative to
say haitians as you um just showed in
terms of what's happening at the border
that's a very uh revealing example of
what haiti not only means
uh to the united states but what it
means to the world at large in terms of
populations from formerly colonized
geographies as well as black brown and
indigenous people in this country who
knows something about the treatment of
racism at the hands of the us government
so in many ways haiti should be looked
at as a singular metaphor for explaining
so many of these um various
mistreatments and levels of preference
for different groups and i think the
more we learn about haiti the more we
realize how our fate
and i'm and this is not an understate um
an overstatement our fate is actually uh
directly connected to it if we um are
going to better understand
what world we're living in with regards
to how the powers that be um intend to
engineer the world um towards uh
imperialism our fates intertwined uh
going right back to uh the u.s not
recognizing haiti's independence for
decades fearing that a slave uprising
would inspire enslave people in the
united states to rise up westernly
astonished thanks so much for being with
us asian american professor at fordham
university where he teaches courses on
the atlantic slave trade the american
abolition movement and afro-caribbean
history and thank you gerald horn
professor of history and african
american studies at the university of
houston author of many books including
confronting black jacobins the u.s the
haitian revolution and the origins of
the dominican republic